so yes I'm very excited to uh talk about
state of the art of probabilistic
programming today
um it's not always that I get the chance
to
um explain my view of how I think like
all these different things are connected
because there's a lot going on and a lot
of moving parts and it's all very
exciting but I think it can also be a
bit confusing so hopefully today uh we
can shine a bit of light on on these on
on what is happening
so
um
already was introduced but um I uh
studied cognitive neuroscience at Brown
before that I uh did my PhD in my
masters in bioinformatics in tubing in
Germany that's where I grew up and
that's where I'm right now I'm in Berlin
Germany
and uh during my PhD I got really
interested in Basin modeling and uh and
pime C because I already loved coding in
Python and then got involved with John
salvatier and Chris Wallace back at that
time to write what was then called pymph
G3 which was
um the first one that was built on
theano and tensor Library
um as of two and a half years ago
um I uh with a couple of other very
talented open source developers
basically the the primec group we
launched uh PMC Labs uh the Bayesian
consultancy
um Twitter seems to uh seems to die down
so you can also follow me on Mastodon uh
based on clubs where the cool kids hang
out apparently
um so yeah so primary Labs I thought I'd
just give a brief introduction so uh as
I said we are the team that uh developed
it well a subset of that team right but
we formed all of the core development
team and I couldn't be more excited
about the quality
um of of the people that that I get to
work with every day to solve some of the
most advanced
problems in Industry with Bayesian
modeling and of course use the resources
and the dedication we have to also of
course drive time C forward and in
general probabilistic programming as a
whole so
um this has been really interesting to
see also how business relates to that
and at the end I'm going to talk a
little bit more about that
so
um
uh yeah so that's uh that's part of the
team
um Christian Lumen isn't on here but
he's also definitely a good part of the
um of the we like to call ourselves the
Basin Avengers
um and that's that's how I think we
um we we strive to be
um
so
uh recently I found this website called
starhistory.com and they allow you to
look at the history of GitHub Stars over
time for what kind of different
repositories and I thought it would be
interesting to compare
um how the some of the most popular
packages have fared over time and I
think it's quite interesting so uh
there's obviously Prime C here in in red
um the Stan there's pyro numpyro
tensorflow probability and touring Julia
package
and I mean overall I think this shows
that the
um the trend overall is is upwards and
it's really great to see that there's so
much interest in these Technologies and
overall that the
um that there are many new packages
right I think there's a lot of
innovation that can still be done and
new packages bring new ways of trying
things out so I think this is very
exciting obviously I'm also excited that
like uh privacy is doing well
um however I like this is just GitHub
Stars right so I don't claim that this
is representative of uh I mean it's
represent of something I just don't know
what it is right
um for example I mean I would still
assume um that the that the user base of
Stan is is larger than that of uh Pi MC
and obviously that's not represented
here so I think this is saying something
but yeah I don't think it's really uh
overall popularity or user base or or
how good a package is right it's
unrelated to that but I think it's
interesting
um to uh to look at where things are
headed
um
so before diving into other things a
quick announcement out of the way
because I will be talking a lot about
this layer of the technology stack
um
so uh originally Pine C was built on
theano which was uh the first tense of
tensor Library out there before
tensorflow and uh pyro came along uh
pytorch came along
and then the theater develop stopped
developing and that left us in a bit of
a pickle so
um with uh some the work of some Brave
individuals like Brandon Willett he took
theano and forked it to uh Sarah and uh
basically overhauled the whole package
and like did really amazing work there
and and this is a lot of what I'll be
talking about the Innovation that is
coming from that layer
um however
um we the pine C team have been
um trying uh have have really started
also to focus on that very same layer
because that's where a lot of the
Innovation really these days is coming
from as you'll see
um but there were sort of different
um I guess development philosophies and
also emphasis on like what technologies
uh should be pushed like obviously from
the pine C side we care about features
very specific to Prime C like for
example name dimensions and certain
optimizations that mainly mattered for
Prime C and
um that I guess shouldn't be really
included in Sarah which tries to be a
general purpose Computing package so
um basically we're trying to get the
Best of Both Worlds by
um taking our Sara and forking it to
what we call Pi tensor and then
um having Pi MC rely on that and then
sort of be able to uh innovate from both
directions right and like get more
development speed for the things that
really matter to Prime C
um
but nonetheless like amazing work by um
by the rsr team and it's what I'll talk
a lot about
um for the full announcement and some
more background you can go here
um so here is uh the first Trend that I
see which I think is really the most
exciting thing that's going on is uh
what I call the great uncoupling where
we can roughly categorize these packages
into
um different approaches
and I would say there's uh for example
the monolithic approach right so there's
a very classic old packages the first
ones bugs but also modern packages that
are like really powerful like stem
obviously
and um they are uh I think both of them
are written in C plus and they write
their Standalone packages so they have
like some libraries but overall They
Don't Really they build like their own
technology stack like with the
computational block probability and
those kind of things
is mostly handled uh specific to that
library right
um
and
then I think the newer packages right
they try to
um
move away from that and make use of all
these very powerful core technology that
we have now which is that tensor layer
so
um obviously we have
uh pyro which Builds on pytorch we have
numpyro which Builds on Jax we have
tensor probability which was classic
built on tensorflow but they have also
now added a another back-end Jacks so
you can select in terms of probability
which one of those two backends you want
to use
and um and this is something that I
think is very powerful is to really
um detach all these different things
from each other and
um
and have them integrate and there's a
lot of power that comes from being able
to mix and match different Technologies
so Pine C I think is like pushing this
to the extreme
um where I would call this then
multi-packet right so tensor world is
like has two backends already but Pi MC
has
um
well really three currently but this in
principle no limit to being able to add
them and so so basically I think it's
the approach of like trying to build an
ecosystem of different things and this
is what I meant in the beginning when I
said well this is all very exciting
right but if you look at this it's like
a whole bunch of stuff to like know
about and at Pine C we will always try
and make this accessible Through Time C
without you having to know really what
is happening underneath all this uh but
I think it's interesting
um even though it might be a bit
confusing um but that's what I'm gonna
try and explain
so obviously there's the Arby's package
which
um spawned out of pine C and
is uh providing like a back end for
storing samples and state-of-the-art
visualizations and that's
um that that is really cool and actually
also can interact with all these other
packages so
um being able to
uh Branch things out and then pull
resources around certain capabilities
that are shared across packages allowed
RVs to develop like capabilities that
were far beyond uh what we provided with
primec
and similar with uh Sarah or I guess Pi
tensor um
where uh that layer of abstraction
allowed to Target different compute
engines
and that includes jacks just like these
other ones but also includes number
um it even includes pile diet and I will
be talking about each of those and how
these things then interact
so I guess I haven't really talked about
how that really looks like but you can
think about this as PMC pymc being the
high level model description way this is
how you write the model with um nice ux
and UI and
then under the hood
um things happen where we build a
representation of the computation that
you're trying to do and usually there's
going to be the log probability but it
can be more it can be lock probability
and the sampler or variational inference
or just forward sampling right
and this probability graph
um
then can be optimized
um and there's all kinds of interesting
things and you can compute gradients
right so this is the idea of like
tensorflow and all of that but
oftentimes
um
these two things I married like
tensorflow for example right gives you
the graph engine but then also handles
like the compilation and execution of
that but I think it makes sense to try
and distinguish between those two so
with our star and Pi tensor you can
Target different backends
um so you can Target jacks or you can
compile that compute graph to number and
then execute it in number
um or the classic one of course that the
Tiana developers had included was just C
so they would just like write C code
but there's also some part of that that
in cython so really there are almost no
limits to what you can do and this makes
it future proof right because like any
new framework that comes out
um we'll just be able to write it back
and for it
um and
so as I said like this allows for some
really interesting combinations of
Technology
so for example
um
the using the Jax backend um there's a
very cool Library by Remy luff and uh
jumping lau and some other developers
there's called blackjacks and it
provides inference algorithms written
directly in Jax so it has the nut
sampler it has
um Pathfinder which is like a new
variational inference method and a whole
slew of other very uh Advanced
state-of-the-art samples and entrance
algorithms
and
what is cool as well because it's
written in Jax right and pine C models
can be compiled to Jax we can just
interact directly at the Jax level so we
can plug those two things together
um and then have like a pure Jacks
program Jax graph that we can just give
to Jax and make it have low level
optimizations and have it make
um different execution engines right so
we can run it then on the CPU or the GPU
or the TPU and Pi MC is totally
oblivious to any of that complexity we
just ship it off to Jax which is like
designed for just that
and well why would you want to do that
um
well speed is probably the primarily
primary reason
um so Bayesian scaling of Bayesian
computation has always been a big Focus
um and something important and something
where like incredible progress has been
made over the last
um
five years uh basically any year like
there's been big strides being made
um so with this like there's a blog post
I mean this isn't like a comprehensive
um Benchmark across models this is like
one model uh that uh we ran
and uh compared between Stan and pine C
without anything so this is the runtime
so lower is better
um on a like fairly sizable data set
um a Prime C compared to Prime C running
on Jax so this is actually using the
numpyro sampler but blackjacks gives
similar results uh but using only Jacks
right so now the sampling and the model
is happening at the Jax level
um and and that of course removes any
python overhead so there's speed up
coming from that and just jacks being
fast
and then as I said we can also run this
on the GPU uh which speeds things up
even more and then you can also run
around the GPU vectorize and that gives
another nice speed up so It won't always
be faster in our practical experience it
almost always makes it faster but it's
not a guarantee but it's so simple to
try out right this is the one line code
where you say well instead of sampling
um classically just sample on
um
um sample using Jax and and the
Blackjack sampler so very simple to just
try out and and for some models it makes
a big big difference
um but really the combinatorial space uh
there are very little limits so for
example there is
um
the nut pie sampler something which
Adrian's eyeball has written and I'm
personally very excited about
um and he wrote a nut sampler which is
the Workhorse of
um basically any big mcmc Library these
days
um in Rust and I personally don't really
know much about rust but
um he has improved the mass Matrix
adaptation so just the tuning of that
algorithm is is better but also it
allows to write very efficient simdi
code so vectorization
um is is happening in multi-threading
and all that good stuff and of course we
don't have a rust back end right
um only that sample is written in Rust
but
the number back end which we do have
through Sarah is
Computing the monologue p and
um and number is uh has a cool feature
where you can just get a c pointer right
so we just get something which we can
pass then to rust because rust can use
just a c pointer and then again remove
any python overhead and just get very
very fast execution and this seems to be
even faster than the Jax stuff probably
for two reasons I mean one is number
could be faster for that particular
model that we tried right so again these
aren't like comprehensive benchmarks but
it just shows what is possible
um
but in this particular instance it took
sampling from 36 seconds to 0.5 seconds
so it was 70 times speed up which is
like insane right for again a one-line
code change so there's nothing the user
has to do
um you just like use different back-end
technology and all of a sudden like
things just start flying
um so this is very very exciting it's
still in the early stages experimental
but um it works and it won't work on
like every model it still depends on
like a lot of work for number to be
completely supported but it's extremely
promising and definitely something
that's
um starting to mature so check out not
Pi if you're interested in this
another cool thing that this approach
allows is I sure I'm sure most of you
have heard of Pi script and piodite
which brings python to the web browser
and allows you to run python code
via webassembly which is a technology
which all browsers now support and
they essentially yeah compiled python to
webassembly and a lot of the other
packages so it's not that it's a small
subset but you can use numpy and pandas
and matplotlib and everything that you
need
and
thus because primec also has a python
backend so you can just run it in Python
just no one really does that because it
tends to be so slow but in this case
that's exactly what we need we want to
just compile the pi MC it's not really
compilation at this point right but it's
just running python code that computes
the mod monologue probability and then
executing that python code as you would
any other python code in piodight and
then you can run it in the browser so um
I thought I'd give a quick
um demo of what that looks like so here
I have a Jupiter light and Jupiter light
is really awesome especially Jupiter but
also running completely in the web
browser so there's nothing on my machine
that's running I you can just go to this
website right yourself and it'll bring
this up and I can then pip install uh
micropy MC
um there's like a small modification we
had to do but in the future it'll be
easy to like do the standard pymc
package and then you import it and you
just write your PMC model this is a
simple beta binomial model you call
sample it'll tell you that there's no
compiler found right so it'll default
back to the python backend which is
exactly what we want
and then samples
um
completely in the browser and it's
actually
um so I mean this is a very simple model
so um we can't really say too much about
speed yet but
um
it's not it's not embarrassingly slow
and of course we have access to all our
other libraries like Arby's too
and then plot things
uh so that's very cool
um so then other cool stuff
um
one thing that I thought was really neat
is
um Ricardo Vieira has implemented Auto
marginalization
um so often
when you have discrete parameters in
your model that makes it very hard
because you can't use samples like nuts
right so nuts only works on continuous
parameters
um so you can mix and match even though
that's sometimes a bit dicey and that's
not guaranteed to work but
um
ideally what you want to do is
marginalize out the discrete parameters
but that requires math and uh I'm very
lazy so and not that great at math so I
don't really want to have to do that
um so instead what this allows me then
to do is to
um Define different models but so this
is just a different type thing that has
this capability I write the model this
is basically the switch point model so
we have a Time series and then a
discrete point in time where we switch
to a different
um time points or like the coal mining
disaster if you're familiar with that
but it doesn't really matter what the
model is
um just note that it has discrete
parameters
at the switch point
and
so we couldn't sample this with nuts
right
um but then we can just hear called
marginalize and give it the parameters
that will not just over and it'll behind
the scenes basically do the
marginalization for us and then be able
to well if if that was the only discrete
parameter it is in this case
um but a sample this nuts and get a
better convergence and all of that so
um yeah this is again like very
experimental and early but uh well state
of the art right that's what we're here
for
and then
um
another cool thing is uh something I'm
personally also very excited about is
causal inference which has been getting
a lot of attention recently because it's
a very interesting approach to solving
many applied business problems right so
in marketing for example you have
campaigns you can't always run a B test
so you want to run quasi-experiments
essentially where you say okay well
um what would have happened if we had
and not run the campaign and then you
compare that to having run the campaign
and
and this causal inference framework is
very powerful and provides many
interesting ideas
um but oftentimes either uncertainty is
not really
um considered or it's coming from a
frequentess background
um and for a while I was actually quite
confused because both of them can build
dags right so what are the differences
but it turns out that there's many uh
similarities between Bayesian modeling
and causal inference and it makes a lot
of sense to try and combine The Best of
Both Worlds um to what then would be
called Bayesian causal inference
and uh also very excited that um we just
released a new package called causal Pi
which uh worked by Ben Vincent
and he
um basically wrote like all of the
different methods that you can do like
differences within differences and
um
uh causal impact analysis uh all at your
fingertips and it doesn't marry you to
Bayesian framework like you can use the
frequencies framework so you can pass
inside learn models but you can also
pass in Bayesian models and then get of
course uncertainty in your content
impact analysis and has nice plots and
all of that so we're very excited about
this package
um definitely check it out and also Ben
is giving a talk
um at Pi data Global called what if
called reasoning means based inference
um here uh yeah check it out and also
check out the if you go to the primary
Labs website there's an announcement of
this package that goes into more detail
business so
um yeah just this is like basically on
the statistical domain
and its last uh
um point
I also think it's very interesting to
consider where the business applications
of Bayesian modeling is headed so and
like with pimps Labs now uh with a very
unique position of really seeing
firsthand what people are using prime C
and probabilistic programming for and
the biggest applications that we've seen
are by far are in in marketing
um where for example we want to find out
what is the expected Revenue per
customer right so we have different
people sign up to our website and buying
stuff
um what is the expected lifetime value
of them and of course because we're good
basins we're getting posterior
distributions so this is uh one example
graph where for every customer on the
y-axis we get a posterior distribution
of what we think the lifetime value will
be for us
usually when you have business data you
have time service and oftentimes you
have spatial data so and very rarely are
these really bottled in the right way
way like really modeled the geospatial
structure
um but of course with pi MC and
um it's calcium process support you can
build
geospatial models that model the spatial
distribution of your data so yeah we
have Alexa say marketing campaigns in
these different counties
um
you can model their similarities taking
the distances into account and that is
very powerful
um I already mentioned the causal
inference
um here especially marketing again if
you run campaigns this is something that
you really are interested in and of
course marketing attribution so you're
spending money on Google Facebook ads
all these different channels and you
want to know how effective they are in
driving the number of users and there's
a lot of work that we did at times Labs
with hello fresh for example
so definitely check out our blog for
many more
information on these media mix models
so here's some pointers so primecio for
the open source project primary Labs IO
for our project drop in email
also quick announcement uh we're running
time C con
um as a web series this time so it's
going to be basically a conference
that's drawn out
um we're in a call for proposals
um that's about to end I think tomorrow
um so if you want to get in under the
wire that's fine if you want to wait
there will be another call for proposal
in um one or two months so this is not
something that's going to go away uh
we'd love to hear how you are using
prime C to solve all kinds of problems
um so this this will be really cool
um
and then also if you want to learn Basin
modeling uh together with Ravine Kumar
and alexandora we have launched an
introductory course called
intuitive-based uh intuitivebase.com
that really like without much math uh
skills required
um we try to teach you this in the most
intuitive applied way possible and uh
people seem to dig it so that we're very
happy about that there's also now an
advanced regression course that's
currently in beta that's going to come
out soon
um with Tommy carpeto Alex Andorra and
Ravine Kumar that also looks really
really cool so definitely check that out
so I talked for longer than I should
have I hope this was interesting I'm
very happy to uh any questions and start
opening up this